schauen wir schon mal aufs nächste
tagesordnung stella das ist das
heizkostenzuschuss gesetz die
bundesregierung möchte einen einmaligen
heizkostenzuschuss für bedürftige
auszahlen alleinlebende
wohngeldempfänger sollen einmalig 135
euro bekommen wer bafög oder
ausbildungsbeihilfe bekommt 115 euro bei
haushalten mit zwei personen ist das
noch mal anders das soll jetzt hier in
erster debatte diskutiert werden bevor
es in die entschlossen in die ausschüsse
überwiesen wird
dazu gibt es auch schon erste
reaktionen die linksfraktion hat dazu
gesagt dass das nicht reicht es die
verbraucherzentrale zum beispiel
sagt dass mindestens 500 euro nötig sein
hier gab es nochmal geburtstags größe
für die bundesministerin für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen klara
geywitz
zwischen bestrich hier noch aufhören
alle sitzen in der fdp fraktion sehe ich
noch zwei kollegen die
beratungsbedarf haben vielleicht anders
die bundesministerin ladens hat das j
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin vielen
dank für die segenswünsche
sehr geehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete ist ein schöner anlass an
seinem geburtstag zum heizkostenzuschuss
zu sprechen das ist das erste vorhaben
was das neu gegründete
bundesbauministerium mit auf den weg
gebracht hat im rahmen dieser
formulierungshilfe und es ist auch eines
der prioritären vorhaben des
bundeskabinetts gewesen was das auf den
weg gebracht hat und für mich hat diese
premiere in dreifacher hinsicht eine
hohe signalwirkung
zum einen wird damit gezeigt für uns für
die bundesregierung ist beides wichtig
nämlich bezahlbares und klimagerechtes
wohnen das hat absolute priorität und
ich werde mich immer dagegen aussprechen
dass man das eine gegen das andere
ausspielt
zu jahresbeginn haben wir erstmalig das
wohngeld automatisch an die neat und
einkommensentwicklung angepasst und die
im koalitionsvertrag festgeschriebene
einführung einer klimakomponente beim
wohngeld werden wir ebenfalls angehen
eine meiner ersten amtshandlungen war es
die bundesmittel für den sozialen
wohnungsbau für 2022 auf den weg zu
bringen noch im dezember haben wir uns
mit den ländern auf eine milliarde euro
für den sozialen wohnungsbau
verständigt wir brauchen hier mehr tempo
und deswegen biete ich den ländern eine
weitere milliarde an und zwar nicht
irgendwelche sondern klimagerechten
sozialen wohnraum im neubau
im neubau wollen wir den sozialen
wohnungsbau im standard e h 55 fördern
die verwaltungsvereinbarung werden wir
nun zeitnah mit den ländern verhandeln
und hoffen sich auch bald abschließen
diese neue klima milliarde ist ein
klares bekenntnis für mehr sozialen
wohnraum und für mehr klimaschutz
das bündnis für bezahlbaren wohnraum
treiben wir voran und wollen im frühjahr
zu einer investitions und
innovationsoffensive einladen sehr
geehrte damen und herren hier einmalige
heizkostenzuschuss setzt folgendes
signal
die bundesregierung wird schnell gezielt
und spürbar bürgerinnen und bürger bei
steigenden energiepreisen entlasten
die heizkosten kreise steigen stark an
die bar mieten steigen auch die
zusatzbelastung trifft jedoch nicht alle
gleich stark die belastungen den
einkommensschwächeren haushalten sind
besonders hoch ich denke hier zum
beispiel an sendenerinnen und rentner
alleinerziehende und menschen die wenig
verdienen sie haben deutliche probleme
die drohenden nachzahlungen aus den
kalten wintermonaten zu schultern hier
setzt unser heizkostenzuschuss an er
soll mögliche soziale härten abfedern
doch diese finanzspritze ist dabei eine
von vielen wichtigen maßnahmen die die
bundesregierung auf den weg bringt zur
entlastung arbeiten wir in diesen tagen
in der bundesregierung zwischen den
ressorts intensiv an einer fairen lösung
für die aufteilung der co2 preis umlage
zwischen wiegenden und vermieten im
klimaschutz sofortprogramm möchte ich
zudem die bedingungen für mieter strom
weiter verbessern wir haben hier die
chance die bürgerinnen und bürger für
die energiewende zu gewinnen und für
entlastung zu sorgen
der einmaligen heizkostenzuschuss ist
drittens aber auch ein signal des
miteinanders in dieser fortschritt
koalition wir arbeiten in der koalition
zwischen den ressorts hand in hand und
erreichen so mehr gemeinsam für unser
land
ursprünglich
ursprünglich war der heizkostenzuschuss
für 710000 haushalte die wohngeld
beziehen immerhin 1,6 millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger gedacht im
miteinander mit meiner kollegin frau
stark watzinger und mein kollege
hubertus heil haben wir die sofort
unterstützung sinnvoll ausgeweitet
herzlichen dank dafür
denn das sind ja nicht nur wohngeld
beziehen von den zusatz belastung stark
betroffen auch menschen in ausbildung
mit geringen einkommen spüren die
steigenden heizkosten deutlich daher
waren wir uns wahrscheinlich dass auch
empfängerinnen und empfänger von bafög
aufstiegs grafik
berufsausbildungsbeihilfe und
ausbildungsgeld mit dieser maßnahme
unterstützt werden sollen
unter dem strich werden rund 2,1
millionen bürgerinnen und bürger von
einem einmaligen heizkostenzuschuss
profitieren ich bin in den letzten tagen
häufig gefragt wurden wo man denn als
wohngeldbezieher einen antrag stellen
muss um diesen einmaligen
heizkostenzuschuss zu bekommen die gute
nachricht ist gar nicht den gibt es
automatisch weil wir nicht nur schnell
sondern auch unbürokratisch helfen
wollen
klara geywitz hat hier den
heizkostenzuschuss
vorgestellt hat noch mal gesagt
wohngeldempfänger kriegen denn
automatisch bei bafög bezieherinnen und
beziehern sieht das allerdings anders
aus die müssen einen antrag extra dafür
stellen
auf klara geywitz folgt nun im michael
breilmann für die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen vor dem hintergrund stark
steigender energiepreise
beraten wir heute einen gesetzentwurf an
mit dem die ampel koalition versucht der
entwicklung mit einem einmaligen
heizkostenzuschuss
insbesondere für wohngeldempfänger
rinnen und empfänger entgegenzutreten
dieser schritt ist grundsätzlich erst
mal richtig
erreicht aber bei weitem nicht aus und
es ist frau ministerin gerade nicht der
große wurf so wie sie ihn da vorhin
dargestellt erforderlich ist nicht eine
halbherzige sondern eine dauerhafte und
nachhaltige lösung die die steigenden
energiekosten abbildet und darüber
hinaus
darüber hinaus müssen auch wege der
entlastung für menschen gerade mit
mittleren einkommen und familien
gefunden werden auch die dürfen wir
nicht im stich lassen das ist doch heute
auch in der debatte zu den
energiepreisen deutlich geworden sie als
bundesregierung und als koalition sie
müssen endlich handeln
denn es ist ja bereits dargestellt
worden die gestiegenen
beschaffungspreise für strom und erdgas
auf den energiemärkten führen zu
erheblichen belastungen bei vielen
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und ich
selber habe viele jahre alt mit als mit
rechtsanwalt gearbeitet viele
haushaltung familie mit gerade kleinen
und mittleren einkommen bekommen dass im
geldbeutel schon seit jahren zu spüren
viele menschen haben angst auch bei mir
im wahlkreis vor der neuen
nebenkostenabrechnung sie haben sorge
dass sie die heizkosten noch bezahlen
können und ja es sind nicht nur
finanzschwache haushalte von den stark
gestiegenen preisen betroffen vielmehr
sind die effekte wirklich bis weit in
die mitte der gesellschaft spürbar und
sie haben es ja gerade selber
angesprochen dieser 1 einige zuschuss
der hilft nur etwa zwei millionen
menschen in unserem land und lasst uns
zu wenig
kommen wir aber auch zur umsetzung des
gesetzes wir können als unionsfraktion
nicht nachvollziehen dass diese regelung
dieses einmaligen heizkostenzuschusses
in einem eigenständigen gesetz außerhalb
des bewährten wohngeldgesetzes erfolgt
innerhalb des wohngeldgesetzes würde
klarheit zur zuständigkeit der gemeinden
zur ausführung dieses gesetzes
hergestellt und die umsetzung nach vor
den vorschrift nach den allgemeinen
verfahrensregelungen des
wohngeldgesetzes nord und auch müssen
wir darüber diskutieren der
personenkreis ist gerade angesprochen
worden ob dieser anspruchsberechtigte
personenkreis nicht auch ausgeweitet
werden sollte so sollte jedenfalls auch
eine ausweitung des heizkostenzuschusses
auf alle kinderzuschlags empfänger nach
dem bundeskindergeldgesetz die kein
wohngeld erhalten erfolgen hier und auch
bei anderen tun müssen wir nachjustieren
und ich bin daher auf die
ausschussberatung und die anhörung in
den nächsten wochen sehr gespräch viel
mehr und das haben wir heute morgen
schon des öfteren gehört muss diese
bundesregierung aber auch kurzfristig
handeln und weitere maßnahmen angehen
und hierzu liegen die vorschläge der
union ja auf den tisch viele rednerinnen
und redner haben die auch angebracht wir
brauchen eine senkung der mehrwertsteuer
auf lebenswichtige energie die
heizkosten eine schnelle abschaffung der
eeg-umlage und eine senkung der
stromsteuer auf das europäische
mindestmaß das ist so schnell wie
möglich erforderlich
und beim wohngeld beim boden geld
konkret darf es nicht bei den von der
koalition hier vorgeschlagenen
einmaligen heizkostenzuschuss
bleiben hier gebraucht doch nicht es
schien so als ob herr fricker inzwischen
fragen stellen wird aber wir brauchen
mit auch eine dauerhafte eine
nachhaltige erhöhung des wohngelds und
eine vitalisierung und das alles hätten
sie schon längst angehen können die
koalitionäre sie kündigen aber immer nur
an
vollmundig aber die umsetzung ist wenn
überhaupt nur herzig und zögerlich und
lassen sie mich zum schluss kommen die
ampel ist mit dem versprechen angetreten
deutschlands zu einem klimafreundlichen
land zu machen was gutes fürs klima wird
günstiger was schlecht ist teurer das
kündigten sie im koalitionsvertrag an
und versprachen insbesondere menschen
mit geringeren einkommen zu unterstützen
wir als unionsfraktionen wir nehmen wie
da beim wort dämpfen sie endlich den
preisanstieg bei den energiekosten
senken sie umfassend staatliche abgaben
ohne lassen sie die bürgerinnen und
bürger richtig führen
[Applaus]
es gab leichte verwirrung weil
ursprünglich gedacht war das sei ihre
erste rede deswegen hat herr fricke dann
doch keine zwischenfrage aber es war
schon ihre zweite und insofern
wurde nur erklären warum es hier so
aufgeregt war es weil sich der inhalt
also glaube ich im versicht erinnert als
nächstes hat das wort die kollegin hanna
steinmüller für bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und lieben frau
ministerin herzlichen glückwunsch zum
geburtstag auch von mir was gibt es
schöneres als die erste lesung vom
heizkostenzuschuss gesetz zum geburtstag
ich freue mich sehr für sie und für uns
die
preise für fossile energieträger wie öl
kohle und gas und internationalen den
letzten monaten stiegen darüber haben
wir heute vormittag schon ausführlich
diskutiert für die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher in deutschland bedeutet dass
das heizen immer teurer wird der hype
der anstieg ist von wohnung zu wohnung
sehr unterschiedlich aber eins ist klar
gerade für menschen mit geringem
einkommen wird der anstieg besonders
deutlich zu spüren sein in einer welt
leben diese menschen oft in häusern oder
wohnungen die schon lange nicht mehr
saniert wurden in dem noch ein alter gab
gas alte ölheizung steht die über decken
und wände viel wärme verlieren und deren
bewohnerinnen und bewohner oft nicht das
geld haben um selber zu sanieren oder um
in einen sanierten wohnung umzuziehen
und andererseits fallen dann steigende
fixkosten ganz besonders auf das
bedeutet davon an anderer stelle gespart
werden muss bei freizeitaktivitäten
bei der nachhilfe für die kinder oder
eben beim monatsticket für die bahn und
um diese zusätzliche belastung für die
menschen mit geringen einkommen
abzufedern haben wir den
koalitionsverhandlungen beschlossen dass
der heizkostenzuschuss schnellstmöglich
kommen muss das ist jeder fall danke
auch an chris kühn und die grünen
vereinbaren wieder ermöglicht tragen
der heizkostenzuschuss ist eins der
unserer ersten gesetze und ich finde es
auch ein zeichen dafür dass wir als
ampel besonders diejenigen im blick
haben die unsere unterstützung ganz
besonders brauchen vom
heizkostenzuschuss profitierten die die
der preisanstieg am härtesten trifft
menschen die sich in ausbildung oder im
studium befinden die vielleicht gerade
das erste mal in ihre erste eigene
wohnung gezogen wird oder ein wg zimmer
und die keine eltern haben die sie da
unterstützen können menschen nicht viele
stunden in der woche arbeiten und
trotzdem nicht genug geld verdienen um
die streitenden saalmieten aus eigener
tasche zu zahlen
und menschen die von einer kleinen rente
leben und deren ölheizung jetzt dafür
sorgt dass ihm die heizkosten über den
kopf steigen mehr als zwei millionen
menschen werden dank dieses zuschusses
etwas besser schlafen können wenn im
sommer die nachzahlung für die
heizperiode im briefkasten liegt
klar ist aber auch und von daher das
wissen sie selber herr kollege breimann
das ist nur der erste schritt uns
braucht ein gesamtpaket entlastung zu
diesem gesamtpaket gehört dass wir
endlich den sofort zuschlags für kinder
aus familien mit geringen einkommen
brauchen
zu dem gesamtpaket gehört auch dass wir
mieterinnen und mieter beim co2 für
wärme stärkt das herz werden
veränderungen brauchen mieter entlassen
und die vermieter sohn geht es stärker
in die verantwortung nehmen müssen und
dann wohngeld müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass menschen weniger abhängig sind von
den steigenden heizkosten
darum haben wir uns im koalitionsvertrag
darauf geeinigt die stärkung des
wohngelds voranzubringen und eine
klimakomponente einzuführen die wir bald
angehen werden
die massiven preisschwankungen bei
fossilen hin 17 machen aber auch
deutlich dass wir langfristig aus der
abhängigkeit von diesen rohstoffen
rauskommen ist durch den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien denn mit
dezentralen energie mit der dezentralen
energiewende vor ort sind wir in zukunft
weniger abhängig von den internationalen
preisschocks der fossilen energie und
dazu gehört auch dass die maßnahmen zur
steigerung der energieeffizienz und
gebäudeeffizienz brauchen denn jede
kilowattstunde die wir nicht verbrauchen
müssen wir nicht produzieren und nicht
bezahlen nur so können wir eine saubere
sichere und bezahlbare energieversorgung
in zukunft sicherstellen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie sehen
wir haben eine menge vor jetzt freue ich
mich aber erst mal darauf dass wir den
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf im ausschuss
beraten ich glaube wir müssen auch
nochmal darüber sprechen ob es nicht
möglich ist dass alle diesen zuschuss
unbürokratisch ausgezahlt bekommen ohne
ihn zu beantragen dass werden gute
debatten darauf freue ich mich und dann
ist es soweit dass wir zügig gibt den
zuschlag an die menschen aus zahlen
müssen die ihnen besonders nötig haben
vielen dank
anna steiner hat es angekündigt nach
dieser debatte wird der gesetzentwurf
erst einmal in den ausschüssen beraten
und wie hannah steinmüller ist auch der
nächste redner mitglied dieses
ausschusses ist das ist der ausschuss
für wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen sebastian münzenmaier spricht
jetzt für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren stellen sie sich mal
vor die regierung bricht ihnen zuerst
ein bein reicht ihnen dann eine krücke
und behauptet ohne regierung könnten sie
jetzt nicht laufen lieber bürger das
wäre völliger wahnsinn würden sie nie
tun exakt nach diesem prinzip verfahren
sie aber hier in puncto
heizkostenzuschuss meine damen und
herren aber fangen wir mal mit dem
positiven menschen ich bin ein positiver
mensch fangen wir mal mit den positiven
nachrichten auch an ich bin ja schon mal
froh normalerweise beschäftigen sie sich
mit irgendwelchen gender klos oder mit
queer feministische außenpolitik oder
sie laden irgendwelche clowns sind die
bundesversammlung ein ich bin froh dass
wir heute hier im deutschen bundestag
mal über die probleme der echten
menschen da draußen reden über die
echten probleme die leute umtreiben und
das explodierende heizkosten ist ein
wahnsinnig großes problem das betrifft
millionen von menschen deswegen ist gut
dass wir heute darüber reden und ich
hatte mich gefreut dass sie hier
vielleicht eine lösung auf den tisch
legen die sinnvoll ist über die man
reden können aber was ist denn ihre
lösung ihre lösungen ist ein einmaliger
minimale heizkostenzuschuss für etwas
mehr als eine million haushalte in ganz
deutschland ganz großes kino was ist
denn mit den anderen 40 millionen
haushalten die nichts bekommen und was
ist denn das auch überhaupt für einen
lösung sie doch dann wieder mal nur an
symptomen herum anstatt endlich mal das
problem an der wurzel zu packen meine
damen und herren haben sie sich mal
gedanken gemacht warum die heizkosten in
der vergangenheit denn durch die decke
gehen sie meine damen und herren von der
abzocker ampel sie sind verantwortlich
für die kostenexplosion bei spritpreisen
bei heizkosten für die enorme inflation
und für den preisanstieg in nahezu allen
lebensbereichen
80 prozent
80 prozent aller deutschen fürchten sich
laut einer aktuellen umfrage vor der
nächsten heizkostenabrechnung und wissen
sie warum weil im jahr 2000 die
kilowattstunde noch 14 cent gekostet hat
und weil sie heute mehr als 32 cent
kostet und diese menschen die sollten
sie endlich mal ernst nähmen und deren
sorgen sollten sie endlich mal ernsten
händen verteilen sie also bitte keine
almosen an einen minimalen
empfängerkreis sondern ändern sie ihre
desaströse politik und sorgen sie so für
eine deutliche entlastung unserer
fleißigen bürger und steuerzahler meine
damen und herren
und wir als fdp fraktion wir haben ihnen
ja konkrete vorschläge gemacht wir haben
ihnen ja vorschläge auf den tisch gelegt
stoppen sie die nullzinspolitik schaffen
sie die co2 steuer absetzen sie die
mehrwertsteuer auf strom gas heizöl
fernwärme und kohle vorübergehend aus
all das werden sinnvolle lösungen des
teuerungsraten sind aber all das wurde
von ihnen im plenum ja abgelehnt ihre
staatliche klima und steuerpolitik sorgt
dafür dass im winter menschen in
deutschland frieren müssen und jetzt ein
almosen zugewiesen bekommen wir als
alternative für deutschland wir kämpfen
stattdessen für eine echte entlastung
aller bürger und wir können sie nur
auffordern hören sie endlich auf
menschen mit krücken abzuspeisen und
ermöglichen sie unseren bürgern ein
leben auf beiden beinen und vor allem in
einer warmen wohnung ich danke ihnen für
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
jetzt wird noch kurz das pult das
infiziert wie nach jedem regen noch
jeder rednerin und ein nächster redner
ist meiner sicht der kommunalpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
steigenden kosten sind eine große
belastung für viele bürgerinnen und
bürger vor allem mit bürger mit
niedrigem einkommen leiden darunter
zuletzt unter den stark gestiegenen
kosten für heizöl oder gas im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir deshalb
vereinbart gezielt diese gruppe zu
unterstützen
wir möchten die besonders betroffenen
haushalte und personen zielgenau
unterstützen das sind das sind jetzt
verschiedene zahlen genannt worden aber
es sind auf jeden fall über zwei
millionen menschen die davon profitieren
als ampel koalition unterstützen wird
damit auch sehr viele junge menschen die
durch ihre ausbildung eine wichtige
grundlage für die zukunft unseres landes
leisten werden als immer mehr ehemalige
lehrer an einer beruflichen schule finde
ich es besonders gut dass unter den
geförderten
370.000 auszubildende und 75.000
personen in fortbildung zusätzlich
unterstützt werden
weiterhin bin ich der
bundesbildungsministerin stark watzinger
dankbar dass auf 65.000 bafög empfänger
ebenfalls entlastet werden können genau
diese jungen menschen die ohnehin auf
jeden euro schauen müssen und durch die
korona krise stark belastet sind
unterstützen wir mit dem gesetzentwurf
maßgeblich
gemeinsam mit der abschaffung der
eeg-umlage haben wir als ampelkoalition
wenige monate nach vereidigung des
kabinetts ein sinnvolles maßnahmenpaket
geschaffen dass viele menschen spürbar
entlasten wird die heißt heizkosten
hingen aber auch direkt mit der qualität
der wohngebäude zusammenhalte und
schlecht isolierte wohngebäude
verbrauchen mehr energie es zeigt sich
in zukunft wird energieeffizientes bauen
eine wichtige rolle spielen um den
energieverbrauch die kosten und co2
im wohnungssektor wohnungssektor zu
senken deshalb müssen wir als politik
vor allem für private unternehmen
anreize und klarheit schaffen damit die
von uns formulierten ziele entsprechend
zügig umgesetzt werden können
es wird in zukunft von besonderer
bedeutung sein wie wir zusammen in
europa mit probleme und aufgaben in der
energieversorgung und dem bauwesen
umgehen die kommunikation auf allen
ebenen von brüssel über berlin und
schließlich zu den ländern städten und
gemeinden muss zusammengeführt und
verbessert werden gebaut wird maßgeblich
in den kommunen wo letztendlich geplant
und festgelegt wird was gebaut werden
soll wichtig für uns sind die zwei
programm mit der eu welche sich direkt
auf deutschland auswirken die richtlinie
über den gesamt energieeffizienz einsatz
von gebäuden und dem plan vor 50 5
statt schluss erfolgt der startschuss
für ein energieeffizientes bauen
wodurch zeichnet sich ein
zukunftsorientiertes bauen aus hierzu
einige anmerkungen neue innovative
baustoffe und bauweisen wir werden mehr
baustoff recycling betreiben müssen um
weniger ressourcen zu verwenden moderne
heizungssysteme und wärmeversorgung und
nicht zuletzt wir müssen darüber
nachdenken wie zukünftiges wohnen
aussehen soll welche wohnungsgrößen
brauchen wir wie wollen wir zusammen
leben wie wollen wir unsere städte und
gemeinden weiter entwickeln wir müssen
die geldmittel des bundes überlegt und
zielgerichtet einsetzen unsere ziele für
neubauten und die noch stärkeren maße
für sanierung und ertüchtigung von
altbauten sind nur erreichbar wenn wir
gemeinsam mit privaten investoren diese
große aufgabe angehen
hierfür muss eine technologieoffene
umsetzung der richtlinien und gesetze in
deutschland sichergestellt werden
die schnelle umsetzung des
heizkostenzuschuss gesetzes ist ein
erster wichtiger schritt um zunächst
soziale härten abzufedern während wir
weiter an der umsetzung anderer gesetze
arbeiten um die dauerhafte preis
angemessen energieversorgung sowie den
bau von wohnraum voranzubringen
dazwischen dank
[Applaus]
randers sie mit war das der
kommunalpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
und in der rede hat nun susanne hennig
welt so das wort sie ist die
bundesvorsitzende der linkspartei aber
in ihrer funktion als abgeordnete hier
im bundestag auch mitglied im ausschuss
für wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen und das hier ist tatsächlich
ihre erste rede hier im deutschen
bundestag
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren es ist zwar gut dass die
bundesregierung etwas zur abfederung der
steigenden heizkosten unternehmen will
aber das gesetz was ich auch vorgelegt
haben das reicht bei weitem nicht aus
frauen greifen jetzt erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch zum geburtstag
sie haben erklärt sollen diejenigen die
eine spürbare unterstützung erhalten die
die steigenden energiepreise nicht
einfach wegstecken können
dieses ziel allerdings verfehlt dieser
gesetzentwurf deutlich und zwar aus drei
kunden ich bin auch betrunken erstens
vier von fünf bürgern machen sich
aufgrund steigender energiepreise sorgen
über sieben millionen
haben schon jetzt zu wenig geld um ihre
wohnung warm zu halten der
heizkostenzuschuss hilft aber nur gut
zwei millionen
viele der nun
knapp über der wohngeld grenze liegt
viele familien die wegen corona und der
preisentwicklung ohnehin schon unter
druck stehen können die eigenen
energiepreise ebenfalls nicht einfach
wegstecken
zweitens die beträge die sie hier als
hilfe veranschlagen sind viel viel viel
zu niedrig
das denken wir uns ja nicht einfach aus
und sie zu ärgern sondern das sagen auch
mietervereine sozialverbände
verbraucherschützerin also experten und
expertinnen die täglich damit zu tun
haben und wissen wie schwer es für viele
ohnehin schon ist über die runden zu
kommen und das nicht erst seitdem die
preise deutlich steigen und damit bin
ich bei drittens
eine einmalige hilfe erkennt doch nun
tatsächlich was strukturell verändert
werden muss
die linksfraktion hat dazu einige
vorschläge
ich will nur drin denn das wohngeld muss
auf basis der brutto war mitte gezeigt
werden
strom und gas sperren wegen
zahlungsunfähigkeit müssen endlich
verboten werden und
menschen in grundsicherungs bezug müssen
die tatsächlichen energiekosten
vollständig bekommen
sehr geehrte damen und herren der
inflation die steigenden heizkosten
treffen auf eine schon vorher
grassierende und unvertretbare
armutsgefährdung
dagegen kommt man nicht mit
unzureichenden zuschüssen an deshalb
das gegenteil von gut ist einmal gut
gemeint vielen dank
sogar die beine der bundesvorsitzende
der linkspartei susanne hennig welt so
wir kommen zum vorletzten redner in
dieser debatte das ist martin
dietenhofen von der spd fraktion und
auch er ist
mitglied im ausschuss für
stadtentwicklung bauwesen und kommunen
und das hier ist auch seine erste rede
im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen im gesamten
wahlkampf vor der zurückliegenden
bundestagswahl hat die
sozialdemokratische partei konsequent
von respekt gesprochen mit dem
gesetzesentwurf zum heizkostenzuschuss
zeigen wir dass respekt für uns keine
leere versprechung ist und wir setzen
das wichtige signal wir sollten lassen
sie wir lassen euch mit den steigenden
energiepreisen nicht alleine
an dieser an dieser stelle möchte ich
mich bei unserem ministerin für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen liebe
klara geywitz ganz herzlich bedanken und
auch noch zum geburtstag gratulieren
natürlich danke dass du dein gesamtes
haus gemeinsam mit den beteiligten
ressorts diesen gesetzentwurf so schnell
auf den weg gebracht hast und das
während des aufbaus eines neuen
ministeriums das ist eine enorme
leistung und das zeigt auch die
entschlossenheit der gesamten amtet
wir handeln hier schnell und
unbürokratisch um die mehrbelastung von
über zwei millionen menschen aufzufangen
und das ist richtig gut so
der starke anstieg der energiepreise der
trifft uns alle aber der trip vor allen
dingen menschen und familien mit
geringem einkommen
denn sie gehen anteilig deutlich mehr
geld für heizung strom und warmwasser
aus und deshalb ist für uns auch ganz
klar dass wir hier gezielt die ihn
unterstützen müssen bei denen die
höheren energiepreise mit voller wucht
zuschlagen und das sind eben die
menschen die sowieso schon auf jeden
euro achten müssen und auch viele
übrigens junge menschen in ausbildung
und studium hier helfen wir ganz konkret
in den letzten wochen laut gewordenen
forderungen nach pauschalen
steuersenkungen im energiebereich die
halte ich für falsch eine schnelle und
gezielte maßnahme wie der geplante
heizkostenzuschuss der ist doch jetzt
viel sinnvoller als eine pauschale
steuersenkung von der auch sehr gut
verdienende menschen wie übrigens auch
die abgeordnetenzahl profitieren würden
wir sozialdemokraten wir setzen das geld
ebenfalls lieber für diejenigen ein die
es am dringendsten brauchen
es gibt stimmen übrigens auch aus der
union die sagen dass der betrag zu
gering sei und zu viele menschen nicht
ausreichen würde lassen sie mich dazu
drei dinge sagen erstens freue ich mich
natürlich riesig dass die werte
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
plötzlich ihre soziale ader entdeckt
haben in meiner erinnerung waren es aber
sie die immer wieder auf der bremse
gestanden wenn es darum ging menschen
und familien mit geringem einkommen
gezielt zu unterstützen um nur ein
beispiel zu nennen die faire teilung der
co2 mehrkosten zwischen mieter und
vermieter wie so oft
wie so oft gilt auch hier sie haben in
der vergangenheit blockiert und die
ampel löst jetzt
zweitens ist die höhe des zuschusses
natürlich nicht einfach aus der luft
gegriffen sondern sie wurde vom institut
der deutschen wirtschaft in köln
berechnet 135 euro für alleinstehende
dass es für viele menschen sehr viel
geld oder das sollte auch hier nicht
vergessen werden drittens ist der
heizkostenzuschuss nur ein kleiner
baustein von vielen um die menschen bei
steigenden energiepreisen zu entlasten
er reiht sich ein in eine vielzahl von
maßnahmen die ministerin gab es vorhin
teilweise auch schon genannt hat wir
haben die eeg-umlage bereits gesenkt wir
werden sie zügig komplett abschaffen die
automatisierte anpassungen beim wohngeld
haben wir bereits vorgenommen und werden
es noch zusätzlich stärkt wir erhöhen
den mindestlohn auf 12 euro und davon
werden millionen von menschen
profitieren wir wollen jährlich 400.000
neue wohnungen bauen und davon 100.000
sozialwohnungen die intensivieren den
ausbau der erneuerbaren
und machen uns damit unabhängig von
fossilen energieträgern und den
preisentwicklungen auf dem weltmarkt
nicht zuletzt spielt
nicht zuletzt
spielt die energetische gebäudesanierung
eine wichtige rolle um langfristige
kostensteigerungen vermeiden zu können
denn heizkosten sind in schlechter
hinter und schlecht gedämmten gebäuden
um ein vielfaches höher dort schlagen
die preissteigerung um so mehr ein
unsere aufgabe ist also klar wir müssen
wohnraum zukunftsfähig gestalten umwelt
schont und sozial gerecht
von all diesen punkten profitieren die
bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem land
und genau das ist die maßgabe auch der
spd fraktion das ist der weg ganz
herzlichen dank
im ort in den beruf und über was für die
spd-fraktion und die letzte rednerin in
dieser debatte bevor der gesetzentwurf
der koalitionsfraktionen an die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen
wird ist er mit zöllner sie ist für die
cdu csu fraktion die obfrau im ausschuss
für stadtentwicklung war wiesen und
kommunen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die drei großen
themen die die menschen aktuell in
unserem land bewegen ist natürlich und
die ukraine corona und die steigenden
energiepreise und deshalb möchte ich
heute zum geburtstag liebe ministerin
ihnen auch ein lob aussprechen
sie sind die erste ministerin aus diesem
kabinett die mali und konkreten
vorschlag vorgelegt hat der hilft
deswegen danke dafür
die erste die vorgelegt hat aber der
gesetzentwurf da geht nicht weit genug
das sagen nicht nur wir als union und
entgegen das was der kollege vorher
gesagt hat dass wir eben keine soziale
ader hätten genau das gegenteil ist der
fall schauen sie sich mal in der letzten
legislaturperiode an was da auch unter
einem baum minister seehofer alles zum
beispiel beim wohnungs geld funktioniert
hat da haben wir einiges vorgelegt und
desto zu verhindern irgendwelche dinge
zu verhindern da war das wirklich weit
davon entfernt die
wohlfahrtsverbände und auch die fakten
sagen dass das was vorgelegt hat noch
nachgebessert werden muss steigerungen
von bis zu 40 prozent der energiekosten
dass es schon ein hammer und deshalb
müssen wir dinge beantworten zum
beispiel müssen sie beantworten wie
kommen sie auf einen betrag von 175 euro
für einen haushalt warum bleibt der
zuschuss ein einmaliger zuschuss ohne
dynamisierung wie kommen sie darauf dass
das das richtige instrument ist um die
zukünftig tendenziell weiter steigenden
energiekosten sozial auch auszugleichen
schauen sie dazu in andere europäische
länder wie es dort gehen kann dieser
zuschuss darf keine einmalige sache
bleiben und warum er
hält den zuschuss nur der der auch
transferleistungen erhält was ist mit
den menschen mit den kleinen und
mittleren einkommen den kinderreichen
familien alleinerziehenden usw die eben
keine transferleistungen erhalten aber
trotzdem nicht viel verdienen es ist
doch gerade auch das wahlversprechen der
spd unter ampel regierungen der ampel
parteien gewesen dass die energiewende
sozial abzufedern ist und deshalb muss
die debatte um die energiepreise auch
breiter angelegt werden wir haben dazu
heute vormittag im plenum ein
umfassendes maßnahmenpaket vorgelegt
denn es gibt eben nicht die eine
maßnahme sondern es muss ein
maßnahmenbündel sein um diese soziale
frage abzufedern
also anstatt in der nächsten woche allen
ernstes als tagesordnungspunkt die
medien- und kommunikationsbericht der
bundesregierung 20 21 als oder anderen
alten bundesregierung vorzulegen sollten
sie als tagesordnungspunkt dinge
aufrufen die die menschen in unserem
land auch tatsächlich bewegen werden sie
konkret füllen sie die tagesordnung
nicht mithalten berichte lösen sie
probleme wenn sie diese denn auch schon
bekannt haben deswegen schaffen sie die
eeg umlage ab erhöhen sie die
pendlerpauschale denn es ist nicht nur
eine berliner blasen debatte sondern es
geht auch um die menschen im ländlichen
raum dass mehr von dem erarbeiteten
gehalt übrig bleibt und senken sie die
mehrwertsteuer auf energie und bitte
behalten sie die industrie im blick ich
bin staatssekretär kennen sehr dankbar
dass er ein gespräch mit unserer
heimischen glasindustrie geführt hat
diese familienunternehmen in der
grenzregion bayern thüringen sorgen für
tausende von arbeitsplätzen im
ländlichen raum und die haben volle
auftragsbücher
aber es lohnt sich eben kaum noch in
deutschland für sie zu produzieren weil
die energiekosten beispielsweise am spot
markt und bis zu 500 prozent gestiegen
sind weil es die arbeitsplätze dort
unter mögen ist kann ich nicht
garantieren wer diese lücke füllen soll
und deshalb nützt es wenn sie diesen
gesetzentwurf
nachbessern und wir werden sehr als
union dafür dass sie unsere
grundsätzlichen vorschläge reduzierung
der energiekosten als omnibus an der
heizkostenzuschuss gesetzt anhängen
vielen herzlichen dank
so weit im keller die hier die erste
lesung zu diesem gesetzentwurf
geschlossen hat beendet hat